wonderful and amazing people this is
Canadian kitchen experimenter Ted and
rebel he decided to boil a pan of soda
why would anyone do this because he's an
urban legend hello after 1 hour and 40
minutes
his thickened soda is ready for a little
taste test this is insane oh this is one
of the most disgusting pieces of science
on the internet and I've seen a lot of
disgusting science on the Internet so
why is Ted simmered soda so sickening
soda contains two types of sugar
fructose and glucose both of which are
small molecules that taste really sweet
when Ted pours his soda into the
saucepan he heats it up and this causes
all of the water in the soda to
evaporate off leaving the sugar behind
and the sugar undergoes a process called
caramelization so what went wrong
caramelization usually results in really
lovely tasting food however this time
it's gone way too far
fructose is one of those sugars that
breaks down at a really low temperature
and the soda has a low pH which speeds
up that reaction and because he boils it
for so long these sugars are broken down
into their smallest elements there's
some elemental carbon in there and that
stuff does not taste good when he puts
it in his mouth it tries to cool down
from this runny liquid into a solid
which is like a brittle candy the whole
thing solidifies and he is in danger of
sticking his mouth together
don't try this at home just don't